The constant term is going to be 48. And we can actually get this really
quickly. Let's think about how. We can start to simplify this by multiplying
out the first two sets of parentheses. If we do this, then the first expression
we have is going to be x squared minus 4 x minus 12. And then this, of course,
is still multiplied by x minus 4. Now to further simplify this, we know that we
have to multiply every term in this first set of parentheses by each of the
terms over here. So let's think carefully about this for a moment. If we
multiply anything over here by x squared, it's going to have a factor of x
squared in it. So that's not going to give us a constant. The same is true if
we multiply anything by negative 4x, since there are no terms over here that
would cancel out that x. Now if instead, we multiply something over here by
negative 12, we do have the potential to come up with a constant term. If we
multiply negative 12 times x, well, that's going to give us negative 12x. That
won't work. It has an x in it. So the last combination of terms is what's going
to give us the answer we're looking for, a constant. Negative 12 times negative
4 gives us 48. And remember, this negative 12 came from multiplying the
constants in the first 2 expressions that we multiplied together. So the real
way we get 48 is by multiplying all of the constants involved in these
expressions in the original factored form. Negative 6 times 2 times negative 4
is what gives us 48.